today we're talking about the
possibility of apex legends getting a
single player game in its universe as
well as the last of us dev reacting to
some pricing backlash
all right be honest with me how many of
you dreamed about titanfall 3 last night
because well you might want to keep
dreaming respawn entertainment's next
fps single-player game is reportedly
going to be in the apex legends universe
which was already in the titanfall
universe so technically it's in the same
you never mind according to recent job
listings the company is currently
looking to hire for an apex universe fps
incubation title that seems to be aiming
for a single player experience the open
positions include a senior systems
engineer that will design build and
maintain technology that enables the
team to create engaging gameplay and
fantastic experiences as well as a hard
surface artist to quote help build a
brand new respawn single player
adventure respawn is also hiring for a
new game incubation team however it is
unclear if that team is the same one
working on the new apex universe one hit
the comments and let me know which of
the legends you would want to see a full
like single player campaign for or if
you're just preparing to boycott this
until titanfall 3 gets announced
moving right along to the last of us
since the lead up to the release of ps5
and xbox series x and s 70 price tags
have been a bit of a heated discussion
amongst gamers following the reveal of
the last of us part 1 remake at summer
game fest last month many fans
questioned if the high price tag is
worth it for an old game that already
got a remastered version last generation
robert morrison one of the animators
that worked on the remake took to
twitter to address claims that the ps5
version is just a cash grab and said
quote the price of the game is out of my
control and worth is subjective to each
individual you can decide for yourself
if you want it or not all i'm saying is
i'm in awe of the work that an amazing
group of people did on the project a
tremendous amount of passion was put
into it the last of us part one launches
on september 2nd for ps5 with a pc
edition coming at a later date the game
will be playable in 4k at 60 frames per
second and overall it has been rebuilt
from the ground up for the playstation
5. in addition to the base game the
remake also comes with the left behind
prequel dlc which makes me cry
every single time i play it
not not afraid to admit it in other news
blizzard has announced that it is
officially ending the development of new
content for its moba heroes of the storm
however that doesn't mean the game as a
whole is coming to an end blizzard said
its focus will become making sure the
game continues to run smoothly with bug
fixes balance updates and more alongside
the news blizzard thanked its heroes
community and revealed players will be
gifted the quote incredibly rare epic
arcane lizard mount as a token of the
company's appreciation heroes of the
storm was just one of those mobas that i
was just like this might be the one this
is the one that's gonna get me into the
genre and then pokemon unite was was the
next one and it didn't so it's i think
there's no hope for me right i should
just throw in the towel what's what's
next give me a witcher moba that might
do it
that might do it
you